which this way so you need three pieces
of wood in here yeah to make one box
okay so you need three pieces can
open you want me to talk or you going to
add well this is a
simple vegetable box built on the cheap
so this is just made
from uh 7 and 1/2 inch wide I think it
is redwood fence boards this is just a
Cedar uh fence Runner
2x4 just these fence boards come with a
uh uh Dogg ear and cut the dog ear end
off and you have roughly a 6ot
length and I took another
board same thing and cut it for my ends
I just chose 30 in wide a
typical vegetable Bend in commercial row
crop is 40 in and they're starting to
make better use of the ground now with
the Advent of drip
irrigation so this box is roughly 6
by3 and you can do it as simple as you
want or as sophisticated as you want the
key is when you're trying to start
something from seed is you got to keep
it wet once you get the seed wet it
cannot dry dry out or
you'll stop the germination
process and how much you think that is
with the
wood uh this here these fence boards are
you know you can get them between two
and $4 Redwood this was about $4 a piece
this cedar 2x4 is like $2 or less for
the whole thing for an 8ft piece 6ft
piece uh soaker hose you can use use
drip drip actual drip irrigation costs
more there's a lot of pieces it's not
really necessary in a box like this
unless you can get your hands on actual
drip tape that they use in in commercial
farming and they have whole spacing from
everywhere from 3 in to 8 in so you can
um get the water right to your plant but
when you're trying to
germinate new seedlings you overseed
because there's a percentage of seeds
that are not going to make it you know
you look on the pack of seeds they'll
say 85 85 is pretty common 85%
germination rate that mean so you're
going to put more seeds just in because
none of them all instead of putting just
one seed you would put more yeah there's
a potential that 15% are not going to
seed okay even if everything's perfect
just because they are not perfect okay
and then there's other factors outside
here that are going to could cause some
casualties as well well okay so I don't
know if you can see in the camera we
have some seedlings coming up in this
first row so now what is that wir in
there for first well that didn't come
with the hose right no this is common
soaker hose that is cut at the length to
get one wrap or one line for each plant
line and then I since I I cut it you
know it was a 20 foot hose to begin with
or something like that cut it just
bought a
uh garden hose repair fitting and a cap
to cap this
hose and originally I had it just laying
on the directly on the soil and that's
fine but I thought so that it wouldn't
um interfere with any of the seedlings
trying to come through the ground it is
strung
wire just off of where the the plant
line is you can see here's the Sprouts
coming through so it's just an inch off
to the side hang the hose from there and
just kind of suspends it and then it'll
just drip let me turn the water on a
little
bit so where is he the Seas already
where is the little sprouting well
here's if you focus on my fingertip
fingertip okay all along this line there
you see little oh yeah light green
starting to come through oh yeah
nice yeah I think this was uh spinach in
this first row and that's a pretty quick
germinator we have uh carrots cilantro
and I forget what the fourth one is in
this box kale I think no kale no we were
going to save kale for a bigger box but
things most of these types of vegetables
are between 7 days to 2 weeks and
temperatures yeah is a factor there
there's a about uh 8 cubic yards of soil
in here and you could see it could hold
some more but it's really not necessary
to fill it to the brim this is plenty
but a little higher doesn't hurt either
the purpose of the box for one thing is
the one of the main reasons is it will
warm the soil quicker than it will warm
the soil on the flat ground the sun can
hit it from all sides it's isolated it's
a smaller
smaller unit so it'll warm up quicker
that speeds up germination helps
uh helps them get through the cold
nights it's like a moisture yeah plus
yeah
so the wire you just added it there you
attach it with a nail right yeah I just
use some roofing nails on the ends
because they have a wider head and
that'll act act as the anchor it's
nothing fancy I just cut some of the so
I just Twisted the end around put some
tension on it didn't have to be
overtight and I just you can use
anything you want if you have little uh
ties like for closing bags in the
grocery store those kind of twist ties
that's fine I just cut some of the same
wire to make my my hanger there so you
had before you had it right on top of
the soil now you lift it up so it could
uh for what
reason oh just
to just in case the hose is laying on a
Seedling it could you know it could
break the head of the to protect it of
the of The Little Seedling as it's
trying to come through the ground but
they're actually stronger than you think
I mean they can push a dirt clot out out
of their way sometimes when they're
trying to get to the sun they can
actually push a dirt clot out of their
way of course there is a point where
they will just so the reason they sprout
is because they're looking for light
right for the sun yes exactly very
interesting yeah um what about how much
with the whole bik with the so is what
cost them if they wanted to do it to do
one box like this is probably F the wood
you got to buy a soaker
hose uh spool of wire box of
nails
um you know 50
$60 that's not bad so and you the only
only reason I chose Redwood is it's
stands up to being wet better same with
this cedar fence post they they can
handle moisture I mean that's what
they're made for is why they why they
use it for fencing so they're more like
water resistant I mean weather resistant
right yeah they don't they are slow to
rot from contact with
water what about the soil now uh you can
buy organic soil right this is the next
bik you're going to do yeah
there's these are 1.5 so 1 and A2 cubic
feet bags of
organic garden soil you don't have to
use that but
uh any good it needs to be a top soil
not not a soil for uh house plants so it
needs to have a little more uh this is
it says flower and Herb so that's what
you need right flower herbs right here
so how many bags well the these are one
and A2 cubic feet so we got one two
three four five six six of them this is
probably a little more than we need but
we didn't get this first box very full
either uh here's our three fence boards
you can see the dog dog ear we'll just
cut that off to get a nice Square in and
that that was the length I used the
begin and then you take one and cut it
in half right
for the yeah create create the end uh
cut it in half cut it whatever you you
decide how many rows you want to put in
there and you need to look at what
you're growing to determine how much
width you need uh look on the packet of
your seeds if you don't know and what
the what the suggested row spacing is so
you some things like to be crowded and
other things they need some room to
breathe so this right here this is I'm
talking about organic or organic soil
and the wood it would be about 60 if the
one it started right yeah yeah the
organic soil's a little bit more money
and what on this next box what we plan
to do is put uh food waste you know the
husk of avocados banana peels just you
know all that kind of food waste you
have from preparing meals I'm going to
actually put it in the bottom of the Box
before we put the soil in okay and that
as that decomposes you know that's going
to release nitrogen and and other
minerals into the soil so we're going to
we're going to do it we're going to show
them how to do the bags you're going to
put it cut it put it together and then
add the um leftover leftover
right the from the juicing waste yeah
from juicing all that pulp that's left
we're going to food scraps and that's
what is that
called well it it's almost like
composting campus okay like campus
that's what you're going to do campus
which is very good uh it's like a
fertilizer it works as a fertilizer yeah
when the food waste decomposes it's
releasing nitrogen and other minerals to
the soil so it's very very important you
use that instead of
fertilizers and so we'll come back I
feel like that guy from California
what's the name uh huser huser welcome
back uh we show you how to put it
together
and I'll come back and show you how
these seedlings are doing okay here's my
dog Bing the neighbors Jen